[Música]
especial informativo en francés 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y a partir de
este momento los acompaño para los
detalles y el análisis de la que es hoy
la noticia más importante en francia y
que renueva viejos temores en europa el
país galo fue víctima de un nuevo
atentado terrorista esta mañana en la
ciudad de niza un hombre presuntamente
tunecino de 21 años que llegó desde
lampedusa de capítulo una mujer y mató a
otras dos personas en una iglesia
posteriormente hubo enfrentamientos con
la policía y el extremista resultó
herido fue trasladado al hospital y ya
está en custodia el primer ministro jan
castex ordenó alerta máxima en el país y
desde el parlamento uno de sus miembros
hizo un llamado a suspender el flujo
migratorio en la frontera con italia muy
cerca de niza
el presidente de manuel macro no tardó
en trasladarse hasta niza desde el lugar
del atentado o calificó los hechos de
terrorismo islamista macro en envió un
fuerte mensaje en contra del extremismo
y anunció medidas como el aumento del
dispositivo militar en el espacio
público para proteger al país
desde esta mañana decidimos aumentar la
vigilancia en toda francia para
adaptarnos a la amenaza terrorista
decidí que nuestros militares estarán en
las próximas horas más movilizados y
pasaremos en el marco de la operación
centinela de 3.000 a 5.000 militares en
nuestro territorio en el tú y tu familia
al ser mil militares o no forzar
y así tendríamos la posibilidad de
proteger a todos los lugares más cultos
particularmente las iglesias para que la
fiesta de todos los santos pueda
celebrarse en total seguridad también
protegeremos a nuestras escuelas para la
próxima semana
el presidente también envió un mensaje
de solidaridad para niza y para el
pueblo francés
el segundo mensaje que tengo es para la
ciudad de niza para los habitantes de
niza tan atacados por la locura
islamista y el terrorismo islamista es
la tercera vez que el terrorismo ataca a
su ciudad y sus habitantes
bill voss de vito terceros ok yo sé el
shock que vive su ciudad nuestro país y
yo creo que el mundo entero que nos mira
de manera que yo envío un mensaje de
solidaridad para toda la nación
de su creación
y pidió como he hecho repetidamente en
previos ataques la unidad gala
en francia no hay una comunidad es la
comunidad nacional le quiero decir a
todos nuestros conciudadanos sin
importar su religión si creen o no creen
en este momento debemos unirnos y no
ceder ante el espíritu de división ni en
el gañán sede al distrito edificio
france24 está en niza hasta allí se
desplazó nuestra periodista natalia ruiz
para reportar de primera mano las
impresiones después del acto terrorista
natalia gracias y para empezar quiero
preguntarle cómo encontró la ciudad a
los ciudadanos a su llegada
muy buenas tardes para ustedes pues este
es de nuevo una población que está en
shock porque pues esto vuelve a traer
esos recuerdos muy amargos de 2016 de
ese atentado terrorista sobre el paseo
de los ingleses aquí en niza y la gente
hemos hablado con algunas de estas
personas que dicen estar en shock pero
hay una señora que me decía que ella
había cantado con la coral en la
basílica de nuestra señora de aquí de
niza y que ella de alguna manera sentía
en estos últimos días que había uno de
alguna manera como un ambiente un poco
extraño después del atentado terrorista
en el que murió sam y él para ti este
profesor de colegio hace por un par de
semanas se acerca a parís así que ella
decía que creía que había como algo que
se estaba alimentando poco a poco y que
había generado pues que terminaba hoy
por ejemplo pues en esta serie de
atentados finalmente que se han
presentado en el país se además de esto
pues hemos visto varias personas que han
pasado por aquí han venido a tomar fotos
a dejar estar en un momento digamos un
poco de recogimiento y al mismo tiempo
hemos visto por ejemplo los a taxistas
que se han mostrado bastante solidarios
con lo que
está sucediendo y de hecho han puesto
cintillos a negros sobre sus carros en
señal de duelo
bueno natale a ustedes llegó en tiempo
récord hasta niza que medidas inmediatas
ha visto usted que se tomaron en la zona
del ataque
bueno pues hay muchísima policía
alrededor en realidad como ustedes ven
no podemos acercarnos más a esta pues de
la de la basílica alrededor hay un
dispositivo policial bastante importante
cuando llegamos hace cerca de una hora y
media pues alcanzamos a ver por ejemplo
la policía forense que estaba haciendo
su trabajo aquí ya ellos se han ido pero
la policía ha continuado acordonando la
zona y en realidad ha sido presidente
imposible incluso para los habitantes
que tienen sus apartamentos en esta
calle que ustedes ven a mis espaldas
incluso pasar desde esta mañana había
una señora que decía yo estoy en shock
pero además no puedo entrar a mi casa
porque por ahora pues hay que demostrar
que se vive donde es un lugar de
residencia que es en esta calle se hemos
visto algunas de las personas que
trabajan en las oficinas aledañas que
han comenzado
salir así que se ha visto muchísima
policía hay que saber que niza es una
ciudad en donde no solamente hay
muchísima policía sino es la ciudad de
francia en donde más cámaras de
vigilancia hay en el país
bueno natalidad y ahora quisiera
preguntarle a tratando de no entrar en
el territorio de la especulación cuáles
son los detalles que se conocen a esta
hora del atacante
pues por ahora digamos que de las
fuentes francesas solamente han dicho
que se trataría de un tunecino de 21
años que habría llegado a francia o
había llegado a europa
lampedusa pero han sido más bien los
medios italianos los que han dado un
poco más de información es todo esto por
supuesto hay que verificarlo
completamente con las autoridades
italianas pero según explican este joven
habría llegado que nacido en marzo de
1999 habría llegado a lampedusa desde
túnez a finales del mes de septiembre y
allí habría estado en una barco pasando
una cuarentena por causa del hobbit y
allí después de esos quince días habría
recibido un permiso que le permitió
entrar a territorio italiano estuvo en
la región de julia en la ciudad de bari
y allí estuvo y hay digamos que se
pierde un poco la pista de este joven
hasta el día de hoy cuando está aquí en
francia así que hace muy poco que está
acá de hecho se sabe que eso sí que la
fiscalía- tunecina va a abrir también
una investigación hace un momento
ustedes destacaba la comunidad es una de
las ciudades que están más resguardadas
en francia y es que esta no es la
primera vez que las ciudades objetivos
terroristas recordamos con mucha
tristeza natalia cuando en 2016 un
hombre arrolla con un camión a los
asistentes a un desfile por la fiesta
nacional de francia 84 personas muertas
decenas de heridos y ahora a makro
nakhon se ha convocado un consejo de
defensa para el día de mañana se sabe
que otras medidas podría dar a conocer
por ahora pero lo cierto es que ya pues
francia ha elevado a lo máximo está
alerta terrorista lo cual le permite
pues al gobierno por un tiempo limitado
imponer ciertas restricciones pero hay
que también tener en cuenta que
justamente a la medianoche de este
jueves es cuando comienza el nuevo
confinamiento por espacio de un mes de
aquí hasta normalmente el primero de
diciembre así que esto de alguna forma
esta medida podría venir a ayudar a
calmar un poco la situación a poder no
necesitar tampoco desplegar aún más
fuerza policial aunque como ya lo decían
pues dentro de esta fuerza centinela que
es la que se utiliza digamos para
patrullar en todo el país pues hay siete
mil militares que van a estar por todo
el país y resguardando los lugares de
culto y sobre todo los colegios
justamente cuando este lunes pues los
los niños y los estudiantes vuelven a
sus clases porque a pesar de que hay un
confinamiento lo cierto es que el
presidente quiso que los colegios y los
liceos permanezcan abiertos así que
habrá que esperar que otras decisiones
podrían haber tomarse en este consejo de
defensa pero quizás os van a ser más
decisiones de ver lo que está pasando en
las redes sociales y si hay allí dónde
digamos se están preparando de pronto
nuevos atentados o mirar a ver si este
si este atacante día de hoy pues si
tenía algún tipo de lazos o con algún
tipo de líder
digamos islamista radical no tal ya me
despido de usted por ahora pero seguimos
conectadas a la espera de nuevas
actualizaciones de la noticia este
ataque llega a menos de dos semanas
después del asesinato del profesor de
samuel para ti al igual que en ese
crimen este jueves hubo también una
víctima decapitada sumada a otras dos
muertes se trata de una nueva tragedia
para niza una ciudad turística que ya en
2016 fue escenario de un ataque
terrorista
-juan pupiales nos trae un recuento de
lo ocurrido esta mañana
[Música]
eran aproximadamente las nueve de la
mañana y un aire de incertidumbre
golpeaba niza de nuevo un ataque
terrorista sacudía la ciudad en esta
ocasión era la basílica de notre damme
una iglesia en el centro de la ciudad
que en ese momento nos celebraba
servicio alguno
la presencia de la policía hacía temer
lo peor un sujeto armado con un cuchillo
entró a la iglesia y mató a tres
personas dos fieles y un sacristán
acabamos de ver en la televisión que el
sacristán de nuestra iglesia fue
asesinado
estoy en shock aún me lo imagino lo veo
caminando encendiendo las velas
escuché sirenas la policía llegó rápido
muy rápido llegaron en moto y luego todo
lo demás yo fue una de las fieles una
mujer mayor fue de capital de la iglesia
el sacristán también murió en este
recinto y la otra víctima mortal llegó a
escapar con mi vida a un bar en donde
falleció eran de los pocos que en ese
momento estaban en la iglesia la policía
redujo al atacante un sujeto que según
los primeros indicios llegó solo al
lugar del crimen
no hay ninguna duda sobre las
motivaciones y la determinación de este
agresor quien constantemente repetía ala
es grande mientras era asistido
médicamente soplas
hace 4 años otro ataque de corte
islamista en luto a niza un hombre a
bordo de un camión arrolló una multitud
que presenciaba los tradicionales fuegos
artificiales del día de la bastilla el
ataque terminó con un saldo de 86
muertos y cientos de heridos
y vamos a ir al contexto para eso le voy
a dar la palabra a mi compañera de
france24 valentina torres sánchez y
valentina cuatro años después niza
vuelve a ser un objetivo terrorista el
temor por este tipo de actos en nombre
de la religión se remonta hasta el 2015
así es ángela y como pues lo hemos
hablado también es algo que viene desde
la última cosa del último mes han
ocurrido numerosos hechos que han
generado muchísima inquietud muchísima
preocupación entre las personas
recordemos que el pasado 25 de
septiembre se produjo un ataque que dejó
a dos periodistas de la agencia
audiovisual de mí el niño heridos pero
estaba dirigido a la sede del semanario
charlie hebdo el 2 de octubre el
presidente manuel macro en anuncia un
plan para combatir lo que llamó el
separatismo islámico que será presentado
el próximo año posteriormente el 16 de
octubre fue el día esta fecha trágica en
la que asesinaron al profesor samuel
para ti a las afueras de parís según la
fiscalía un joven de origen checheno
como represalia por haber mostrado una
caricatura del profeta
en su clase el 24 de octubre el
presidente turco recep tayip erdogán
afirma que macro necesita tratamiento
mental por su plan contra el separatismo
islámico aunque aún no sabemos realmente
de qué se trata este plan es un plan que
se presenta en un año y desde el 25 de
octubre empieza un boicot y unas
protestas en países de la órbita
musulmana contra francia con turquía
liderando esa consigna posteriormente 27
de octubre como ya lo habíamos hablado
charlie hebdo hace una caricatura con
erdogán como presidenta y turquía
anuncia medidas legales contra el
semanario por último tenemos esta
trágica jornada de luto que es lo que ha
ocurrido hoy en niza y en otras zonas de
francia y en otras instituciones de
francia bueno eso por el lado de la
historia y le pido ahora a valentina que
nos hable acerca de las reacciones que
llegan desde el extranjero y vamos a
empezar pues recordando algunas de ellas
sí señora el presidente macrón aseguró
que este es un ataque contra todo el
país pero especialmente contra la
comunidad
el papá francisco desde el vaticano
lamentó lo ocurrido aseguró que es un
momento de dolor en un tiempo de
confusión y añadió que el terrorismo y
la violencia no pueden ser aceptados
ahora también tenemos que decir que los
ataques de hoy se producen en medio de
la atención que están viviendo
turquía y francia desde que el
presidente manuel macro nace este
anuncio de su plan contra el separatismo
islámico algo a lo que su homólogo turco
respondió pidiendo un boicot a los
productos galos como ya lo decíamos y
asegurando que macro necesita un
tratamiento médico sin embargo hoy ante
la jornada de ante lo que hemos visto el
gobierno de ankara emitió un comunicado
en el que condena enérgicamente el
ataque terrorista perpetrado en niza y
destacó que ninguna razón puede
justificar el asesinato de una persona o
justificar la violencia las reacciones
también llegaron desde la unión europea
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen calificó el ataque
de atroz y brutal al tiempo que rusia
centró su mensaje afirmando que es
inaceptable
los sentimientos de los fieles
religiosos e inaceptable asesinar
gracias a ustedes de valentina y en
efecto las respuestas desde fuera son
diversas llegan palabras desde
dirigentes internacionales y también
desde la comunidad musulmana tanto
francesa como internacional matías
arraes nos compiló las más importantes
pocos instantes después del ataque la
ola de reacciones de mandatarios
europeos invadió las redes sociales el
primero de todos fue el cercano vecino
de la ciudad de niza el italiano
giuseppe conté el infame ataque a la
catedral de niza no debilitará nuestro
frente común en defensa de los valores
de la paz y la libertad nuestras
convicciones son más fuertes que el
fanatismo el odio y el terror estamos
cerca de las familias de las víctimas y
de nuestros hermanos franceses si la
mayoría de los mensajes mostraron la
convulsión internacional una
intervención desató el rechazo el ex
primer ministro malasio mo and bad
mártir echó leña al fuego en twitter una
declaración que minutos después fue
borrada los musulmanes tienen derecho a
estar enojados y a matar a millones de
franceses por las masacres del pasado
afortunadamente el llamamiento de las
autoridades religiosas musulmanas de
francia fue diferente el consejo francés
de culto musulmán pide a los líderes
musulmanes que cierren sus mezquitas
hasta nuevo aviso a partir de esta noche
después de la oración nocturna y que
usan este último momento de oración como
una oportunidad para él
y el recuerdo en memoria de las víctimas
un mensaje global de rechazo hacia el
atentado
la iglesia católica llamó a la paz ya la
hermandad entre religiones y es que
francia no solo está viviendo lo
ocurrido en niza en la ciudad de lyon
fue detenido esta mañana un hombre
afgano que portaba un cuchillo y que se
disponía a entrar a un tranvía así mismo
fuentes policiales confirmaron que un
hombre que amenazaba a los transeúntes
con un arma de fuego en la ciudad de
aviñón murió por disparos de los agentes
los oficiales le pidieron que se
deshiciera del arma pero al rehusarse
abrieron fuego por último un guardia de
seguridad en el consulado francés
ubicado en la ciudad saudita de jeddah
fue atacado con arma blanca
las autoridades condenaron el ataque y
aseguraron que nada puede justificarlo
existe conexión entre estos nuevos
brotes de violencia contra la bandera
francesa con esa pregunta les quiero dar
la bienvenida a nuestros invitados
expertos de hoy desde madrid se conecta
a fernando 8 analista de inteligencia y
riesgos a la seguridad nacional y desde
parís nos acompaña eugeni richard
analista experta en relaciones
internacionales comienzo con el gen y
podría por favor de darnos su
apreciación
bueno aquí tenemos entonces un clima un
poquito tenso como ustedes lo han dicho
ya son muchos asuntos que se acumulan y
que hace que los franceses no están
viviendo de manera serena tuvimos un
montón de asuntos que tienen que ver con
el islam y hay una cierta tensión en la
sociedad francesa acerca de este tema el
29 de octubre es una fecha importante
para el islam es el aniversario de la
fecha del nacimiento del profeta mahomed
no sabemos si eso tiene importancia así
porque hoy entonces sucedieron estos
hechos un caso es que efectivamente y
francia- y manuel marco ya empezaron una
nueva etapa en su política tanto
interior como exterior en el cual el
islam va a tener una posición central
todos la que toda la clase política
empezó a reaccionar hoy a decir
necesitamos mucho más que nuestras leyes
necesitamos
darle más duro al islamismo necesitamos
que nuestra presidente responda a lo que
está pasando y al cual el presidente
está intentando responder con
tranquilidad y la necesidad de estar
unidos todos contra la lucha contra el
terrorismo y de por favor no hacer el
amalgama entre islam e islamismo entre
los musulmanes franceses y los
terroristas que en su gran mayoría no
son franceses entonces si bien de pronto
no hay una conexión evidente entre todos
estos hechos si hay un ambiente que es
propicio a las tensiones y unos actos
así bárbaros pero de unas personas que
no están conectados necesariamente entre
sí pero que son unos radicalizados y que
deciden de su manera personal y
improvisada cometer un acto terrorista
para hacer pasar un mensaje porque estos
atentados fueron perpetrados en contra
de símbolos un profesor que enseñaba la
laicidad y la libertad de pensamiento
ahora una iglesia católica entonces
pensar que son símbolos es una guerra de
símbolos que es propio del terrorismo
desde hacer guerra de manera económica
para generar un montón de un máximo de
trauma en la sociedad y una atención
mediática
importante gracias y fernando su
análisis por favor pero coincido con mi
compañera el terrorismo tiene como
función básica generar miedo y generar
terror o sembrar miedo y sembrar terror
es decir generar una estabilidad
económica política y social durante los
últimos 10 15 años ha habido una
continua presencia de islamismo radical
que ha ido de los cristianos católicos o
no eran minoría se establecía una
persecución permitida o tolerada por las
fuerzas policiales incluso por los
gobiernos vemos en la conversación del
ex ministro malayo en este caso en
francia que es el país laico por o sea
no no aconfesional si un laico por
definición por sistema centralista
establece que toda persona que tiene una
religión no puede hacer una licitación
pública de ella en un espacio público
eso implica que los islamistas radicales
ven a francia ya los modelos como los de
francia como él
lugares a los que derrumbar a los que
atacar y es algo algo que se vaya
padeciendo muchísimos años no desde
ahora desde la famosa cruzada del da es
contra occidente y desde hace muchísimos
años francia es un polo de atracción
para radicalización puesto que es o fue
un polo también de colonización en este
caso en áfrica o en otros países en este
caso concreto el regreso del tunecino
nos hace llevar a cabo un análisis
histórico de lo que ha sido la recluta
islamista en los diversos territorios y
vemos que a pesar de ser touré con un
país que era muy tolerante antes de
todas las primaveras árabes es el origen
de grandes masas o mucha gente que se
afilió tanto al danés como al qaeda o
mcvey y ahora también en francia ha sido
un inmigrante de origen tunecino el que
ha generado este atentado como bien dice
mi compañera no hay un hilo conductor
claro pero si hay un clima social de
este caso un clima islámico
el terrorismo islámico en el que si se
busca cómo poder hacer daño de manera
aislada o conjunta al pensamiento
francés de pensamiento laico cómo es ese
pensamiento ese pensamiento es un riesgo
un riesgo desde el punto de vista
educativo el punto de vista social pero
también de poderes económico lo que
intentan los islamistas radicales
intenta cualquier terrorista es siempre
o bien desestabilizar el estado o bien
subvertirlo y ponerse en su lugar esta
segunda parte es imposible por tanto lo
que intentan es conseguir que francia
eleve el nivel de alerta eleve el nivel
de presión sobre los musulmanes y así
generar mayor tendencia al islamismo
radical por parte de los islam los
musulmanes en francia tenemos diciendo
que es una lástima pero me temo mucho me
temo que vamos a seguir viendo atentados
no sólo en francia y en otros países
porque vuelvo otra vez a ver una oleada
bastante importante de visibilización si
efectivamente eso es lo que hemos visto
justamente francia ha subido a su nivel
máximo de alerta y eugeni hablaba a
fernando coche hace un momento de las
acciones de manuel macro ni es que lo
vemos
ha adoptado una posición de liderazgo de
fuerza frente a sus socios europeos y
francia de hecho lidera los esfuerzos
antiterroristas en el extranjero
no hace más que ver que la operación en
el magreb islámico en áfrica y la ley de
control de la enseñanza del islam en
francia lo que estamos viendo hoy son
repercusiones de esa serie de decisiones
sin duda sin duda ahí tenemos unas
repercusiones a este tipo de decisiones
que ha tomado el presidente emmanuel
makoun hay una serie de sucesos que cada
vez que francia toma una decisión en
contra del islam ya lo vimos también
cuando el presidente prohibió el porte
del velo para las mujeres en el espacio
público pues ahí tuvimos los países
del medio oriente que andrew reaccionado
cada vez que francia ha tomado una
decisión para defender sus de sus
principios de laicidad de libertad de
pensamiento y más que todo de garantizar
la laicidad dentro del espacio público
tenemos una reacción digamos en golpe
dentro del territorio entonces
efectivamente allí el estado francés
seguramente se está alistando para tener
varios tipos de reacciones de este
estilo pero otra vez quiero señalar que
estas reacciones son la iniciativa
privada y propia de unos individuos que
generalmente actúan de manera aislada se
trata de unas personas que son pocos
socializadas que son radicalizadas solas
y que actúan de su propia iniciativa es
decir que este tipo de terrorismo
finalmente individual es mucho más
difícil de combatir porque se trata de
unas personas que no están
necesariamente conocidas de los
servicios de inteligencia o de personas
que no necesariamente presentan un
perfil a riesgo así que
todo toda la sociedad francesa que va a
vivir en este estado de emergencia ya lo
votaron hasta el 16 de febrero y
seguramente vamos a tener un ambiente de
tensión
ahora bien vamos a entrar esta noche en
el segundo confinamiento porque el
presidente francés dijo que ya la
segunda ola del cubil estaba más aún
alarmante que la primera y la sociedad
francesa va a estar confinada en su gran
mayoría así que seguramente pues allí
tendremos una sociedad más más tranquila
confinada en casa
pues la agenda mediática también y
política va a cambiar
durante las semanas de venir
entre tanto fernando le pregunto a usted
que es un experto analista en seguridad
la última semana la noticia fueron las
protestas en los países musulmanes fotos
de macrón quemadas fue lo que se vio en
los medios de comunicación indignación
porque se muestran imágenes que recrean
al profeta mahoma la protesta es un
derecho pero qué pasa cuando eso se
vuelve un brote que termina en
terrorismo que reflejan estos actos
violentos y extremistas que de ninguna
manera corresponden piensa usted al
sentir de la comunidad musulmana
por supuesto la comunidad musulmana en
su inmensa mayoría es pacífica y cumple
con sus ritos hay un doble un triple
problema que se mezcla en seguridad en
inteligencia es cierto que son
individuos radicalizados muy pocos lo
que más llamados se llaman lagos
solitarios porque los solitarios otras
cosas y son gente que busca en un
entorno un caldo de cultivo radical
busca un comportamiento que pudiera
generar una llamada de atención a los
hermanos musulmanes
es obvio que cuanto más sea el
confinamiento y cuanto más sea la
polarización de ideas así más radical
será la respuesta de los radicales
islámicos porque porque están
consiguiendo en última instancia lo que
quiere decir que la población tenga
miedo ellos no que desean que la
población musulmana sea libre desean que
la producción musulmana se vea sometida
al escrutinio oa la vigilancia y con eso
conseguir generar un mayor índice de en
este caso de afiliación al radicalismo
islámico en francia
este este hecho nos lleva a una segunda
derivada la segunda derivada es que la
seguridad nacional en francia está por
encima de los derechos de muchas
ocasiones derechos religiosos por ser un
país laico entonces el problema reside
en que los cristianos no ejercen fuerza
de violencia mientras los musulmanes
radicales si lo hacen y eso provoca que
francia o país laico sea el receptor
siempre de riesgos cada vez mayores de
ataques por radicales islámicos
en la tercera derivada es que
evidentemente estamos en un momento en
el que la declaración de turquía tampoco
ayudan y la de creación de otros países
tampoco ayudan nos encontramos una
polinización una visión geopolítica
diferente francia se ha convertido en la
punta de lanza de europa europa de su
vida como en otros países se convierte
en la punta de lanza de reivindicar una
serie de derechos ahora habrá que ver si
con la modificación de la ley que macro
está intentando conseguir ahora
conseguirá minimizar los riesgos pero
como bien decía mi compañera son pocos
aislados y que no necesitan una
dirección estratégica para generar un
acto terrorista joven son cuchillos son
acciones rápidas son acciones
individuales y eso no se puede controlar
pero ese es el objetivo del terrorista
al no poderse controlar al no saber qué
musulmán es bueno que musulmán es malo
ya han ganado en lo que se llama la
narrativa de la violencia ya han ganado
una imagen del musulmán como enemigo
entonces musulmanes recibirán presión y
esto generará mayor contra
en francia es un juego de ajedrez gran
juego de ajedrez en el que no estás solo
en un jaque la seguridad nacional no
está solo en jaque las ideas religiosas
o políticas sino que está en jaque es
una visión del mundo de valores de un
tipo o de otro tipo entonces yo creo que
habría que poner pie en pared hablar
claramente y establecer qué tipo de
acciones sociales económicas no solo
religiosas habría que poner en marcha
para no digo evitar pero sí minimizar
este impacto podemos estar de acuerdo a
libertad de pensamiento tendremos que
darnos cuenta de que cada sociedad cada
cultura o esa de mi compañera avanza de
forma diferente y las caricaturas de
cuestiones cristianas ya han sido
tomadas como algo normal pero para mucha
gente las caricaturas u otras acciones
en el terreno musulmán atentan contra
sus principios identitarios porque su
proceso de evolución social y político
es diferente y al ser diferente estamos
intentando que sean como nosotros cuando
tienen un proceso de evolución diferente
y por tanto cambia
si escriban de cambiar de una forma
diferente como hicimos nosotros yo
recuerdo en españa no hará muchos años
unos 30 o 40 años como había una
radicalización religiosa en el que por
ejemplo las mujeres no podían abrir una
cuenta de banco sin el permiso de sus
maridos a lo de españa no hablo de
países extraños eso ha habido una
evolución rápida
veamos qué evolución tienen los países
musulmanes ese es el punto de entrada la
ayuda a la radicalización sabiendo qué
es lo que hay que hacer es un disfraz
social político de acuerdo político en
el que una vez más el países como
turquía no están favoreciendo no
más adelante quisiera señor 8 que
habláramos un poco acerca de esta ley
que permite la blasfemia en francia pero
antes de tocar este tema quisiera
preguntarle a eugeni desde el punto de
vista de las relaciones internacionales
pues de erdogán es desde turquía
encabeza este es llamado boicot a los
productos franceses y como un mensaje
pues es claro rechazo al estado francés
pero en la práctica que tanto depende
francia de su comercio con los países
musulmanes como podría llegar realmente
la afectación con este llamado boicot
bueno es más que todo una respuesta
simbólica cuando hablamos de boicot
efectivamente para la economía francesa
no estamos hablando de un país que es el
primer aliado comercial de francia y
entonces más que todo es un asunto
diplomático y en diplomacia también lo
que tratamos son los símbolos así que
este boicot y el hecho de que francia
haya llamado a regresar a parís su
embajador de turquía
y eso es más que toda una política de lo
simbólico es como una relación de tire y
afloje que ya está entre en parís y
ankara y lo que intentan hacer entonces
es estos dos países es medirse
como decía mi compañero es un juego de
ajedrez en el cual las fuerzas se van
midiendo se van provocando van tirando
aflojando para ver quién va a ser
primero el boicot más que todo es
simbólico
también turquía condenando el atentado
de esta mañana eso es una respuesta
simbólica también importante las
repercusiones en el terreno
internacional entonces pueden ser
importantes pero yo creo que más
importantes aún van a ser las
repercusiones en la política interna no
hay que olvidar que en 2022 francia
tendrá elecciones y qué
y ahí vemos que toda la clase política
francesa está empezando a construir las
narrativas que van a ser las que van a
dominar el discurso político y mediático
hacia el 2022 imagen de penn que es la
líder del partido de extrema derecha que
ha hecho de la lucha contra el
terrorismo uno de sus grandes temas
electorales se está fortaleciendo cada
vez más parece que es una chiva es la
que viene a que es la más adecuada para
para explicar estos hechos y cada vez
más la sociedad francesa se deja tentar
por este tipo de narrativa así que yo
creo que desde hace unos días con todos
estos asuntos que pasaron en la sociedad
francesa y además la gestión del
confinamiento del joven que no ha sido
tan buena porque estamos en con un
segundo confinamiento pues tengo ganas
de decir estamos en una
lanzamiento de campaña presidencial e
invasión está jugando su capital
político y los otros líderes políticos
están listos para desarrollar su
narrativa su argumentativo para para
posicionarse para las próximas
elecciones presidenciales si no en vano
los discursos de los últimos meses de
manuel macro en contra del extremismo
vamos a hacer una pausa en el análisis y
nos desplazamos nuevamente hasta niza ya
está nuestra enviada especial
natalia ruiz o con una actualización de
lo que sucede justo en frente de la
catedral de nuestra señora de nissan
y después muy buenas tardes como ustedes
se pueden ver ya abrieron un poco más de
la circulación ya nos pudimos acercar
más a la basílica y de hecho pues en el
transporte público volvió a retomar en
la tranvía que atraviesa justamente qué
pasa justamente en frente de la basílica
ya volvió a retomar hay que saber que la
gente pues se sigue viniendo aquí pero
aquí en niza y también una toque de
queda que debe comenzar sobre las nueve
de la noche es dentro de dos horas y
media hay una nueva un nuevo dato acerca
de el atacante de este tunecino de 21
años nacido en marzo del 99 y es que al
parecer vendría de la ciudad de sfax a
de unos 270 kilómetros al sureste de
túnez que es la capital de ese país y
bueno pues por ahora como ustedes ven la
gente continúa llegando vienen a tomar
fotos pero de todas maneras no se puede
estar justamente completamente en frente
de la basílica por ahora no se puede
estar pero bueno ya han dado paso un
poco más la circulación pero como les
decía ya viene este toque de que hay de
todas maneras a partir de la noche de
este jueves a viernes pues comienza
también el confinamiento en todo el té
nacional natalia y recordar que
adicionalmente emanuel macro no puede
ser ha dicho que aumentará el pie de
fuerza militar en las calles vamos a
volver al análisis están con nosotros o
fernando coche experto en seguridad
nacional y también está con nosotros
eugene richards desde parís para hablar
de todas las implicaciones
internacionales y fernando le estaba
debiendo la pregunta sobre la ley de la
blasfemia que protege las opiniones de
los ciudadanos franceses incluso cuando
a veces podrían ser interpretadas como
aseveraciones atrevidas pero hasta donde
esto cruza la línea que no vulnera por
ejemplo la libertad religiosa
es un tema muy delicado es un tema casi
casi filosófico el tema es que a mí me
enseñaban cuando era pequeño que mi
libertad acababa donde empezaba la
libertad el de enfrente cuando yo tengo
un respeto el otro tendrá respeto por mí
es decir antes de pedir que los demás
cambien debemos cambiar nosotros solo
cia ya rené descartes el problema reside
en que la libertad pública libertad de
expresión muchas veces si la sociedad no
está preparada para asimilarla y siempre
habrá un proceso de gente que no lo esté
surgirán que un crecimiento social
político en este caso religioso yo
recuerdo cuando ha habido películas que
han
ha narrado de alguna manera determinada
ciertos pasajes de la religión cristiana
las protestas han sido protestas
razonables protestas moderadas no habido
protestas violentas pero si ha habido
protestas el problema es que el proceso
identitario de los musulmanes está en un
proceso diferente es un paradigma
diferente una narrativa diferente para
ellos la opinión o sobre su religión es
fundamental en su proceso identitario y
da igual que nosotros no lo hagamos con
ánimo de ofensa de libertad de expresión
sino que ellos lo van a ver como un
ataque sí me gustaría destacar unos dos
puntos muy muy brevemente el primero es
que la crispación política y la
crispación social por el confinamiento y
por otros problemas económicos es el
momento en el que los radicales van a
utilizarlo para lograr esa última gota
que colme el vaso y que provoque
reacciones desmedidas o incontrolables
por parte de las fuerzas policiales
francesas por ejemplo y eso es algo que
se provoca sistemáticamente cuando
quieres provocar una revolución lo que
provoca es a la policía
o acciones policiales para convertirse
en mártir y la segunda es llamada de
riesgos a nivel europeo es la mala
política de inmigración y de integración
de los inmigrantes que provenga pro
motivos políticos formativos económicos
o en el caso de los sirios huyendo de la
guerra una mala política europea de
integración no digo asimilación digo
integración estará estableciendo guetos
como ha ocurrido en otros países con en
alemania o en francia parís 4 recuerdo
las manifestaciones de que la policía no
ha podido ni entrar ni siquiera en los
barrios están generando un entorno en el
que es muy fácil prender la mecha puede
que una persona no se radicaliza si no
es porque el afecta directamente pero si
el contexto es un contexto muy radical
un contexto muy crispado cualquier
persona de uno u otro bando puede
radicalizarse puede haber ataques contra
los musulmanes
puede haber ataques contra los
cristianos y eso francia es lo que estoy
intentando con con la nueva legislación
antiterrorista la ley
de la blasfemia lo que está haciendo es
preservar una entidad un proceso
identitario laico es decir todos tenemos
derecho a opinar lo que queramos sobre
lo que queramos pero eso no es
comprendido por la totalidad de la
ciudadanía social y en francia en otros
países entonces el avanzar a diferentes
ritmos establecer diferentes procesos en
un mismo contexto va a llevarse sin duda
a fricciones que van a acabar bastante
mal si no lo podemos controlar y la
extrema derecha de creciente auge en
toda europa incluyendo mi país en españa
es un ejemplo claro de esa visión sotto
voce que está oculta y que espera salir
a la luz cuando existe el caldo cultivo
necesario para sus ideas
recordemos que excepto francia y un par
de países más los países más
radicalizados ideológicamente de extrema
derecha son los países que
paradójicamente tienen menos problemas
con los musulmanes tienen bien los
problemas del terrorismo y han tenido
muchos menos problemas de inmigración es
curioso los países con más inmigración
estadísticamente han tenido más
problemas
de los que no es bueno es que el otro
lado de esta conversación
fernando es la xenofobia y cuánto
trabajo hace falta por comprender la
ideología y las creencias de los que son
nuestros vecinos y en esa línea
quisiera preguntarle por este trato que
se les da a los inmigrantes vamos a
seguir hablando de inmigración entonces
europa como el viejo continente tiene
además de responsabilidad por los mares
de gente que siguen huyendo de sus
países que siguen tratando de llegar a
los países europeos y entre ellos pues
llegan estos atacantes en muchas de las
ocasiones lo hemos registrado con los
ataques terroristas lo que conocemos
como los más llamados lobos solitarios
sí bueno la cuestión de la migración en
francia es central no es algo nuevo es
algo que conocemos desde hace de señas
porque no olvidemos que francia ha sido
una potencia colonial y que tenemos
varios países que fueron colonias y que
hoy son independientes como algeria por
ejemplo y recibimos entonces migrantes
desde los años 60 en francia 11 barrios
llamados a olas migratorias cuando
francia necesitaba fuerza de trabajo en
los años 60 70 y después son estas
generaciones que se instalaron en
francia que tuvieron sus propios hijos
que llamamos los hijos de la segunda
generación y ahora la tercera generación
que son franceses pero cuyos padres son
inmigrantes de países de países del
magreb
esencialmente estos segundas y terceras
generaciones no están bien integradas
hay que saber que hubo una política
fallida de inmigración
de lo que hemos hablado mucho el modelo
de integración republicano francia decía
no importa si usted es francés nació en
francia o si es francés nacido de padres
extranjeros todos somos ciudadanos no
hay distinción ni de color de piel ni de
religión ni y nos damos cuenta que este
modelo de integración republicano ha
sido un gran fracaso y que hoy en día ya
no está funcionando porque estos
hijos de inmigrantes estaban
considerados durante mucho tiempo como
unos franceses de segunda categoría y
entonces hay xenofobia ay sí mucho
resentimiento por parte de estas
poblaciones que encontraron dentro de la
radicalización y dentro del islam
digamos un modelo de reconocimiento de
identidad y que al general sentido a sus
vidas entonces tenemos un modelo de
integración republicano que ha salido ya
hace mucho tiempo y tenemos nuevas olas
migratorias que son nuevas que a las
cuales pertenecen estas personas qué
perpetuo estos actos terroristas que
vienen de los últimos años que
efectivamente también está es el señal
de una política migratoria fracasada
pero como lo ha dicho mi compañero que
no es solamente en francia que es en
toda europa entonces con esta ley del
separatismo islamista
emanuel manjón quiere dar un gran giro
en su política migratoria decir bueno ya
no podemos asumir esta posición que
tuvimos hasta ahora necesitamos
endurecer nuestra legislación y creo que
el pueblo francés lo está esperando
sobre este punto
muy de manera muy radical hemos notado
un giro en su discurso y seguramente eso
es también dado la próxima elección
presidencial que se va a dar será un
asunto crucial para la reelección del
presidente bajó bien pues lo que nos dan
ustedes es el cuadro grande de lo que
está sucediendo y pues nos dejaban más
que todo muchísimo para reflexionar no
se nos olvide que francia es el país con
más musulmanes en europa más del 8 por
ciento de la población conviven desde
hace décadas y bueno estamos a la espera
a las de 9 pm hora parís de la
conferencia quedará el fiscal general
sobre estos temas y siendo esto dicho
puede ser me despido de eugen y richard
también de fernando coche nuestros
analistas del día de hoy y de natalia
ruiz que es nuestro enviado especial y
nos está reportando minuto a minuto lo
que va sucediendo en niza hasta aquí
esta especial pero ustedes continúen con
nosotros en france 24 regreso más
adelante con actualizaciones